it was one of the most emotional nights
ever on Dancing with the Stars and no
moment was better than when Noah popped
the question
I'm Angelique for ET online and we have
the happy couple back States
Jamie the moment that you surprised me
on the show was one of those Simoes
amazing moments I've ever had and you
know the diss song the time of my life
you give that to me and you know I've
got to do this here because this
feeling amazing it was the biggest
surprise of my life I mean it was I had
no clue I wasn't prepared for this I I
didn't I mean totally off-the-cuff like
he outdid himself yet again yeah Shawna
new Shawna
Shauna's job was to hold the ring and
pass it to me drop the ring I was
freaking out because I didn't want to
drop it I didn't even see our school has
come up because I was just holding on to
the ring so tight that it was amazing it
was just such a beautiful moment to be a
part of and that's so perfect for each
other you know and to be there for that
was just awesome
I was I was very nervous you know what I
was going to say you know cuz I if I had
time because you know it's like it's in
the middle of a show so you got to get
it done and you're limited on what you
can do there's all those people in there
yes she could have said no that would
have been horrible but she did yeah I
was told by someone they're like if she
hesitates for a second we'll cut
I mean I've known for you know beyond
since the minute I met her that she was
on me the summer I was on a Mary so how
I was gonna propose to her you know I
had I had made the comment that I've
ever made to the finale on this show
that I'd do it then live on television
and the fact that she surprised me on
the show when they brought her in from
basic training and so many people that
you know the new followers I've gained
on social media from this show follow
our story as well I felt like this is
the perfect place to do it and the
finale may or may not happen because you
know nastya rumor and rocky are so
incredible so I figure the semi-finals
was just as good as the finale yeah oh
my gosh is this really happening like ah
I love this man so much I just it was
like pinch me never in a million years
I've imagined you have got a beard I
just had no clue it's beautiful it's
beautiful like I would have picked it
out myself
yeah yeah true story